Okay Michael, so here's this theorem that
you, you so desperately wanted. You ready?
>> Yep.
>> I'm going to read it to you, because you can't read. In a two player
zero-sum deterministic game of perfect information, minimax equals maximin.
>> Alright you told us what minimax was,
but you didn't tell us what maximin was.
>> Well maximin is like minimax, except the
other way around. So a is trying to. [LAUGH]
>> You know, one side is trying to minimize
the maximum, the other side is trying to maximize the minimum.
>> Okay.
>> It's exactly what we described before, just depends upon whether you're
looking at it from a's point of view or b's point of view.
>> Oh, I see, like, which, do you choose
a column first or do you choose a row first?
>> Exactly, so whether you go a first followed by b,
or b first followed by a. You're end, going to end up
in the same, with the same result. And that, more importantly,
or at least as important, there always exists an optimal pure
strategy for each player. In other words, you can solve those
games and you know what the answer is. Once you write down
the matrix. You just do Minimax, or you do Maximin and you
end up with the proper answer. And now you know what the
optimal players would do. Now there is a subtlety here which
I got it a little bit in the previous slide, when I
talked about rational agents. And what we're sort of assuming in everything
that we discuss here is that people are always trying to maximize
their rewards, okay? So we define the, the
reinforcement learning problem that way. That my goal is
to find a policy that maximizes my long
term expected reward. You know so I'm trying to
find, to get the best reward that I
can. And what you're assuming here is that everyone
else is doing the same thing and they're
assuming that everyone else is doing the same thing.
>> Okay.
>> DOes that make sense?
>> It does thought I'm a little bit stuck on this
word optimal at the moment. Right. Well, that's what I'm trying
to get at actually. That optimal here really means I'm
maximizing the reward that I can get, and I'm assuming everyone
else is doing the same thing. And I'm, furthermore, I'm assuming
that they're assuming that everyone else is doing the same thing.
>> So, so I guess I'm wondering whether. Whether this theroem is
vaccus in a sense that are we defining optimal to be mini max.
>> What we're defining optimal to be, I think.
So that's a good questino. I think I would unroll the vaccus one level by saying
this. Optimal here, basically has to be optimal
in respect to what? And the respect of
what here is the underlying assumption that everyone
is trying to maximize their rewards. And that
everyone knows this. So, in a world where
you have perfect information. It's zero-sum. Then, the strategy
of Minimax and Maximin give you the same answer.
And that furthermore there is always some place where the
column and the row cross, the best column and the
best row cross. And that is always going to be
the solution to that particular game. Now, if we weren't
in a two-player zero-sum deterministic game of perfect information, that
might not be the case. But in a case where
we're in this sort of simplest version, where everyone's being.
Rational, that is, optimal, that is, trying to maximize their, their
own reward. And assuming everyone else is maximizing their own reward, this
is the right thing to do. Now, I've got a little
weasel word here as well which we're going to get to in
a moment which is this notion not just of a strategy
but of a pure strategy. [INAUDIBLE] There's a reason why we have
notions of pure strategies because in the end as we get
more complicated we're going to have to do it with impure strategies.
>> Mmm.
>> Okay, but are you with me so far?
>> I think so, yeah.
>> So basically all that stuff we did in AI with game trees and search
is kind of what you would expect people to do if they knew everything. [LAUGH]
>> So, So, I feel like I could prove this theorum in the case of trees
because you just prop, you just kind of
commute values from leaves up to the root.
>> Yeah.
>> And, it, it doesn't matter. There is no notion of who goes first or
who goes second. So there's just going to be
one answer, to that process. It's not obvious
to me, how to show it, if you, once you've. Turn the tree into a matrix, that
that matrix, I guess because it captures the
same information, it ought to be the case that
this is still true, but like, I'd have to kind of sit down and think it through.
>> No, and it's, so, so, to help you
think it through, I guess what I would suggest is
if you have the matrix, you can create a
tree that's consistent with it. Because every row and every
column represents a strategy. You don't know what
that strategy is, but you can, since it's
a finite matrix. You can construct a tree
that is consistant with that major. In fact, possibly
an infinate number of them, I'm not sure,
but you can certainly construct at least one that
is consistent with it. And then once you
have the tree you just do what you said.
>> Good.
>> Alright, good. So we've got this
fundamental result and now what we're going to
do is we're going to try to be a bit more interesting. But it
is important to go through this because now we've
got some basic vocabulary and some basic building blocks okay?
>> Yep.
>> Alright.